columnist for SB Nation and also on on
Sirius XM radio joining me here day
after the Super Bowl how are you Jeff
Oh fantastic I like that Superboy I know
people are a little down on it but there
was a lot of a lot of genius happening
especially the Patriots oh well I mean
let's talk talk about what in particular
was the genius on the Patriots uh Jeff
that would hold the Rams to three points
it's what they do best and I know people
talk about often but they adapt game to
game play to play have to have him in
even grand plays on offense in the last
Drive when they did tour they weren't
even on the play seat again they did
against the Chiefs as well two weeks ago
but they adapted they basically did what
the Lions did against the Rams a week
thirteen but just better they ran a lot
of quarters coverage they run a lot of
zone covers and one high stuff and his
full Jer golf's notable that that
pressure into that and I thought one or
two things would happen yeah run were
gone to the dancers I thought would be a
mistake because you belts had two weeks
to prepare and this is what happened he
did yeah he didn't capped at all I
thought he would have just someone and
he's gonna move at all and it showed in
the field so will you agree with char
McVeigh's assessment after the game that
he got outcoached which by the way I
thought was really refreshing and
revealing it didn't sound like one of
those wrote yeah I got outcoached today
I really think that he took the the loss
on him certainly knowing that there'd be
a lot of people pointing the finger at
his young quarterback
oh he 100% got out coach like I said he
may know if he does and he tried to do
it and did not work and ready for the
play-action there any sort of for the
one place I'm still shocked at this Todd
Gurley was not getting the reps that he
should I don't know what's happening in
that situation I think he's healthy but
it happens just to not yet yeah I had to
run the ball well but Gurley didn't
forget how to run the football he didn't
forget how to catch the ball he didn't
forget how to contribute out of the
backfield and they had no production
from the running backs in the past game
the open ocean little tight ends in the
whatsoever the pictures just took away
all the options they had no answers so
Jeff Schwartz here on the Rich Eisen
show I pointed out in the top of the
show of two plays it's not like I'm
telling any tales out of school it's the
two plays that so many people are
talking about today
Kooks wide open the Patriots did blow
the coverage yes in that one yes so what
what in golf in your estimation Nazi
Kooks
yeah the safety the safety right there
in quarters the other a throughout the
the deep cross are yawning gulf is
reading that safety on that play and if
the safeties flat-footed he's not hit
the post behind him and i don't know if
he just didn't see this agency i know
it's a placer pass maybe the action took
longer than he thought there was look
like no one in his face and he just
missed it and that's what happened most
of the game guys opening golf just
didn't see them but McCourty i think
that's a recording on the backside there
been a fantastic play that doesn't
happen very often with a backside corner
like that has to run all the way across
the signal to make a play like that but
missed an opportunity he didn't see them
and that was the story of the game there
were opportunity to be half to the Rams
and whether a golf was pressured or
confused didn't make the throws
necessary Jeff Schwartz former offensive
lineman NFL contributor to SB Nation
here on the Rich Eisen show so what did
the Patriots do well on the offensive
side of the ball so many people are kind
of surprised that Brady didn't have
another 400 500 yard night yes he has
been lately well look at Brady of a
chance on sides Brady as one touchdown
three or seven 260 yards so he did you
know he played well in the overtime
period but he played okay in a game he
played okay yesterday but the Patriots
run game again it was the story and they
did it with different players right Sony
Michele had a big game a so they're sort
of Birkhead he came in there and ran the
ball hard and the the the homework for a
good run game is how the Patriots ran
which is early in the game you're not so
hard to come by you grind down a couple
yards here and there you get a eight
your carry get you know one-yard carry
very few negative plays which is which
is great that one player
too technical for loss and then in the
fourth quarter when you have run the
ball without you start losing to defense
and you end up with the long beans which
was really steal the game we saw that
play where they ran out a little one
back power Michele had a big game alas
driving that that's what a good run game
does and the Patriots they neutralize
Donald they neutralize sue for the most
part they use their aggressiveness
against them kind of ran to where they
would vacate knowing that they are hard
pencils up the field it was a special
game plan I think that the Patriots
d-line really annoying and high telex it
has some MVP praise and social office
alarm so when you said that they ran
some plays that were not on the place
sheet I know that Grunk slant in
overtime in Kansas City in the AFC
champion game was one of those how do
you know what was run last night was not
in their play sheet Jeff yeah piercing
reported again the screeners article
that that last drive they decided to go
heavy because they realized that that
the Rams were matching up the personnel
pretty well when patrons were kind of in
their in their normal personal groupings
and they were too heavy personnel to
bring to tony dane's
two running backs and have Edelman only
wide receiver so forced developing in
base defense it have an extra loop
therefore that's when I took advantage
unless it couldn't cover shtetl been on
a bit of linebacker in the middle field
you have wonk and on a corner King
because I had the girls and one
bathrooms you can't tell them and
including Josh McDaniels you know that
was know in the places for the game it
was they practiced all week over the
last two weeks and he called offense
together and said look you know displays
are in our playbook because this was
installed a giant playbook in training
camps I mean a player in the playbook
it was cold I'm on ended right he
entered a known to have a play she those
plays and that's what the pitchers are
so great about just like that and the
fact that you do it all right Jeff if
one more question for if you can hold
your phone out because I think it's it's
it's a little muffled here when it comes
down
to it why is Belichick so and the staff
so able to recognize things in real time
and adjust with you know a roster that
is so flexible in a way that other teams
can't to me that that is the
differentiator and obviously having the
greatest executors on offense in the
history of the game in tom brady is
another another differentiator but just
the ability to do the things that you
say and also have I guess that vast
library to say hey you know what the
lines did here that's exactly what we
did against the Redskins and Kirk
Cousins before and Patricia used that
from us I mean how did how is that
different how did no one at house nobody
else able to do it well I think it's a
mindset of just flexible from from from
start to finish so when they prepare for
a game the thing about all the options
and they're open to doing what works
that week a lot of coaches have egos and
want to do what they do best all the
time right like McVeigh he said we're
gonna run what we know and we're gonna
be the Patriots well
Belted doesn't care he won't wonder
whatever works for him in that week so
takes a coach who doesn't have an ego
and rip Belichick has an ego but one
that really doesn't to just say we're
gonna be so multiple and look and they
have people especially on defense like a
van Noy and the Hightower who can do
multiple things they can rush the passer
they can guard out the back but they can
stop the run so when you have
interchangeable pieces like they do
especially on defense it allows you to
do more things and give more looks and
players buy in but they buy in because
they know they can win a Super Bowl
and how about Julian Edelman Jeff
Schwartz who has signed my book here the
greatest Jews in sports how about I
think he's the first Jewish MVP of the
Super Bowl how about that Jeff he is if
you know he jumps the farthest right up
greatest Jewish NFL players I feel like
he's a short list he jumps well I mean
there's the Sid Luckman there's there's
Benny Freedman who created the modern
pass you know but you know there's no
he's definitely the first member of the
tribe and the membership of the Super
Bowl MVP Jeff I think I saw the Hank
Greenberg the only
their MVP of any sort in any sport for
that is Jewish as well so a very rare
company for Edelman good for him you can
look he played he played very well
obviously was a big they couldn't guard
him and hard that is the way they set
him up formation Aliso he can't get
doubled but he was unguardable yeah yeah
Chris Harris of the Broncos tweeted out
you you better have your slot corner and
be able to play man-to-man otherwise
you're gonna get beat like that so on
off he's trying to talk a pound the
table of his own of his abilities right
there but it made sense made sense hey
Jeff thanks the call man will chat again
soon all right
yeah that's Jeff Schwartz former
offensive lineman the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience